I want to pull up this story from the  post millennial breaking Elon Musk  welcomes ligma and Johnson back to  Twitter so these are these are two  employee a former employees they're  getting their jobs back congratulations  to ligma and Johnson for uh getting your  jobs back no I'm just kidding these guys  they hoaxed the media walked out of  Twitter HQ carrying boxes and then  claimed that they had been fired the  post millennial now reports in an  unexpected heartwarming move Elon Musk  welcomed back quote former employees  ligma and Johnson to Twitter  headquarters today  Rahul ligma and Daniel Johnson are  fictitious names used by two pranksters  who were able to dupe mainstream media  into believing that they were woke  Twitter employees who had just been  fired not everybody was uh it wasn't  just the mainstream media that fell for  it I I of course did a report on it  um mentioning they thought that it was a  hoax so uh turns out it was